what this neighborhood means to me is
everything this neighborhood taught me
what life is
gelato makes happy people
so i want to make people have been
from here you can go anywhere
the first thing to make your dream come
true is to take yourself out of your way
i'm still like dorothy on the yellow
brick road like you know i'm just as
happy every day when i come in here
the process of making the ice cream is
to first and foremost keep it as simple
as possible so i use milk cream
sugar
eggs salt and then i add natural
ingredients from there on
just staying with those humble
ingredients
gives you such great taste
and flavor
and so that's why i've never strayed
from
keeping it as simple as possible
[Music]
well the journey to getting mikey lights
and ice cream on the map is hard work
dedication
perseverance persistence taking a good
idea and continue working it until
it's perfect which nothing can be
perfect you know
as a child always had some sort of
hustle mentality to myself throughout
the years i had an aunt lucy and i would
have to actually go to cooking class
with her after school because my parents
were at work and that's why i started
learning how to cook and then my aunt
passed and when she passed i was
cleaning up the apartment
i found like a book that had
her recipe that students have in there
and one of them was a vanilla ice cream
recipe when i decided that night i was
like hey let me try to make vanilla ice
cream and i didn't have any ice cream
machine anything i just gave it a shot
and it was really bad and i was just
like i can do better than this you know
so i ended up uh doing some research
went to bed bath and beyond but uh
cuisinart table time machine i ordered
different types of vanillas and i was
looking at online and then all of a
sudden
it started to work the machine was
making the better ice cream i was able
to pair different vanillas together then
vanilla was born
what goes on in my head when i develop
recipes really just energy
what i do is i put music on of the
talent that i'm thinking of and i just
let it go and as i'm thinking of the
flavor i just let it come to me and as i
taste you know it's a feeling thing
because you feel good you're changing
something great like all right cool the
role pop culture place is everything
pink floyd was
born through the concept of thinking of
new york when you look at new york
what's synonymous with new york
cheesecake so i went down to juniors one
day i got a strawberry cheesecake my
mind was blown and i was like wow this
is fresh strawberries on top of a great
cooked cheesecake so i was like that got
to be the strawberry here
[Music]
to be honest i'm a kid who just thought
having a cart was good enough this whole
community that we're building with ice
cream
is
really a way to fill a void a problem in
life for some people
i went to jail for six months it was
bittersweet because you think that you
know you don't realize what happens to
those that really love you
and you really hurt them
by being awake you can never make up
that time but the one thing you can do
is play catch up so this is our catch up
here you know this might catch up you
know just making sure that everyone that
comes to the door is treated with love
because they show us love being here
what this neighborhood means to me is
everything this neighborhood taught me
what life is
we saw mom-and-pop shops growing up in
this neighborhood this is the land of
mother and father shops families who set
up something and they hope that people
enjoy it that's where i've gotten like
the whole concept to show other kids in
the neighborhood this is a small
situation
and from here you can go anywhere
as long as you can own your craft that's
why i try every day to
stay in tune with the people to see what
they want because they're the ones who
push us to be the best we can be things
can go great and things can go just as
bad stay positive and keep people in the
right direction let's say
music drives us
you're upset you put on something it
changes your mind it lifts you up gives
you some self-esteem it's something that
brings life to people the history that
we have to teach a lot of kids right now
some of them don't know the musicians
from the past and for us to keep that
always going to pay homage to those who
actually started the whole pop culture
situation
opening the ice cream store was a
peaceful situation for myself and it
makes me feel like my aunt is in the
kitchen with me
she always stressed doing good you know
and helping people so
that's the whole quality
of what this is about
and using ice cream as the tool the
medium the message to get it across food
is the language that is universal
between everyone
but ice cream to me no pun intended was
the best ice breaker with someone so
when my art pass and i found a vanilla
ice cream recipe
that for me was like wow if i have such
peace with just this simple thing how
many other people can do the same
[Music]
gelato is art a new signature flavor is
like a paint or a sculpture
it's something that comes from your soul
i mean something that comes from inside
you it's where you put all your love
gelato still is something new in the
united states ice cream
is made mainly with heavy cream while
gelato is a balanced mix of
milk skimming powder a little bit of
heavy cream means that gelato has less
calories and less fat contains less air
comparing to ice cream and is served at
a higher temperature
the first step to make gelato is prepare
the base
there are different
approach to make this
i make a base
that is good for every gelato and then
when you batch the gelato you take part
of
the meat base and then you add chocolate
paste and then you batch them together
and it comes gelato
i
grew up eating gelato
of course in italy
we had a small gelato machine at home
i had my job in milano in milan i was an
insurance broker
and when i turned 40 i decided that was
not more my cup of tea
at the time i said okay you make good
money and you have to do something in
your life a reason is
gelato makes happy people so i want to
make people
happy
i learned how to make gelato at gelato
university in bologna
it's interesting because
90
of students that i met there
were people that want to change life
they
founded this organization for people
that want to make a change and how to
make this change it was fun and i like
it
gelatin is like bread the day that you
make the bread and the day that you buy
the bread that the baker because they
just made is amazing
that's why we are focused on making
small batches but producing gelato every
single day
i want to let people know
the difference between
gelato and
ice cream and
i won't let
them taste what is a real gelato made
with
premium ingredients
[Music]
is very important where the ingredients
come from to me is very important to
research every day for new ingredients
with high quality
it's not my kitchen it's my lab i spend
most of my days in the lab producing
gelato and developing new recipes for
next
chemistry is balancing ingredients
sometimes i
get inspiration from
simple things
we do
[Music]
gelato i think top quality of gelato
using only natural ingredients
we don't use any
coloring agent or artificial flavoring
justo in this contest means done it
right in the right way i think that we
lived up with the name of geologist
[Music]
my first trip to new york city i was
five years and a half my father worked
for an american company so i had the
chance for many years to come to
the united states i started to love this
city and one day
one of my dream was to move to new york
city
this is
a family neighborhood and we are we have
a lot of returning customers that hang
out at night or after school they bring
the other kids here and there was family
come here and the kid was very grumpy
and then i convinced him okay get the
usual strawberry and vanilla and
suddenly his mood
changed totally i asked the father so
the cure work the gelato makes people
happy and he said yes
[Music]
my name is lorenzo francati i'm a gelato
chef i want to make people happy
it's something that comes from your
heart it's something that comes from
your soul
it's where you do
for your love
just get out there all the stuff that
you have against yourself let that go
for a second and just be the best that
you can and you'll see what happens good
can happen bad can happen but if you're
willing to accept it and grow from it
only greatness will be achieved
[Music]
you